what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers
live together under one roof players
stop being polite
and start getting real this is the
champion
watch out santa claus is coming to town
i
like my candy cane harry
hmm i suppose i should have santa for a
real passport
what gift can you give a man who has it
all uh
humility oh how much is that i'll buy
100 humilities
[Music]
[Music]
get out of here europa house urchin ugh
oh i love
cristiano miss it's a time to put aside
our differences
and receive expensive gifts oh
what is this it's a squishy trophy is it
uh
is it supposed to smell like this all
right all right
this one is for you robert oh cool my
dudes you should not have
oh wow it's so big it must be a
a ballon d'or but we figured you
deserved it this year anyway
hold on hold on who are you to just give
someone the ballon d'or
i mean he was the top scorer in the
bundesliga and the champions league this
year and
bayern won the travel so oh okay well if
we're all just giving the awards to our
teammates uh ronaldo
for uh having the most instagram
followers you get the balador
here no messi is a ballon d'or for
pulling out with bartomeu
give me that well if we're giving out
the ballon d'or
i want the leviathan award for best
goalkeeper oh like you would win
i want that grammy i want a noel peace
prize man
let's close the trophy
here is how we will sail this we will
all get dressed up and gather in the
auditorium
and i will host this year's ballon d'or
it will be
a very tasteful ceremony as long as
everybody
follows my rules okay
[Music]
here are the rules nine men enter
one man leaves
again
wait i don't get it what are the teams i
am very confused
should half of us take our shirt off or
something why did you call it beyond
valendome when all the important stuff
happens
inside your balan dome yeah i guess i
got carried away with all the cool
costumes and production design and
didn't really think the rest of this
concept true
okay okay new rules how about this four
man ander
two men lee those many bands do they
knock around we do this
eight times then we take those sixty men
and put their names in our pot
hey look it's snowing whoa
snowflakes oh it makes me so happy
i love the snow it's a white christmas
oh
oh i hate to be the interpreter of bad
news but that is just asbestos from the
roof
dang it guys what are we doing it's
christmas
we shouldn't be fighting over some award
we should be coming together
kevin kevin's right robert if anyone
deserves the ballon d'or
it's you man you earned it
[Music]
thank you guys that means a lot and
while i 100
deserve the award 2020 has been hard on
everybody so how about this year we all
shared the ballon d'or
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
world um us everyone
[Music]
i need a break after being stuck here
forever doing other people's laundry
when booking my trip
i sometimes wonder what else could
possibly go wrong
i mean that probably won't happen but if
my plans have to change it doesn't
matter because hotels.com has flexible
booking options
hotels.com because just in case
[Music]
like and subscribe to br football or
i'll kick you in the jingle
balls